jean-yves heurtebise il est maître de
conférences à l'université catholique
foule gêne à taipei il est chercheur
associé au centre d'études français sur
la chine contemporaine c'est le vu
d'ailleurs jean yves heurtebise bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur la matinale de rtl france 24
millions d'habitants à taïwan seulement
sept décès 843 cas depuis le début de
l'épidémie ça fait rêver
vu d'ici alors pour être si peu touchés
par l'épidémie
c'est quoi votre quotidien qu'est ce que
vous devez respecter comme mesure
bonjour oui en effet taïwan a été assez
peu touché par l'épidémie même très peu
touchés comme vous le rappelez le début
et seulement neuf morts et environ 1 900
900 cas donc la plupart étant des cas
des cas importés en réalité des cas qui
ont été à pas après un strict contrôle à
l'arrivée aux aéroports qui ont été
directement contrôlé positif et a
ensuite mis en quarantaine
donc pour ce qui est de la vie
quotidienne par pas votre question en
fait celle ci n'a pas notre âme a
tellement changé on peut dire que la
presque pas du tout changé par rapport à
avant l'épidémie si ce n'est que le port
du masque est généralisé dans les
transports en commun et alors qu'en fait
qu'il est surtout nous le port du masque
obligé obligatoire d'un transport en
commun le fait est que les taiwanais le
porte même dans la rue je dirais de fer
sont volontaires il n'y a pas en réalité
de l'obligation de porter le masque mais
c'est en fait à la pratique que la
pratique courante des gens dans la rue
alors en france on a beaucoup entendu
les autorités au début de l'épidémie
nous dire que le virus n'avait pas de
passeport et qu'il était inutile de
fermer les frontières d'assas n'a pas
été la vision du gouvernement taiwanais
oui tout à fait sur ce point je vais
écrire certains articles dans causeur et
aussi dans sur le blog socialiste
certains articles sur la manière dont
taiwan agir et gérer le cas du coc vide
donc il faut se rappeler d'un chrono
dis donc que en fait taïwan a été très
tôt au courant en fait de ce qui se
passait en chine le 31 décembre alors
qu'il ya premier indice d'un cas de cas
de co vide
roanne déjà là la taiwan va contrôler
les arrivants de la ville ensuite de 20
à partir du 20 janvier c'est officiel le
23 taiwan interdit tous les vols du
houran et le 5
elle interdit que les vols qui viennent
de chine hong kong de macao et
effectivement ça c'est cette réaction
extrêmement extrêmement rapide est
primordial pour combattre le virus et sa
diffusion puisque plus plus on attend
longtemps plus il est possible que la
diffusion se propage de temps que
c'était arrivé au moment du début du
nouvel an chinois l'année dernière et
que donc il a vu cette propagation donc
mais il faut aussi se rappeler que l'om
c'est pendant longtemps a déclaré que
c'était inutile de contrôler et de
réduire les vols donc taiwan ne faisant
pas partie de l'om sait et connaissant
la situation en chine a décidé de son
propre chef de prendre des mesures de
restriction des vols et même des
interdictions assez tôt et il faut
évidemment se rappeler aussi que l'om
ses dépens de la chine par rapport aux
données qu'elle a qu'elle peut avoir de
la situation en chine et donc les les
autres pays ont écouté donc plutôt les
recommandations de bruxelles qui jusqu'à
assez tard a dit que c'était inutile on
va dire de restreindre les vols est
effectivement à partir de la partie au
moment où il ya eu ce contrôle il se
contrôle à ces sectes au niveau des
niveaux d entrée ce qui fait que la
plupart des cas comme je disais au début
sont des cas importés des cas de gens
qui arrivent directement qui sont testés
à leur arrivée à l'aéroport qui ensuite
sont mises en quarantaine pour conclure
en quelques mois il reste très peu de
temps vous donc vous êtes français vous
vivez à taïwan
est-ce que selon vous les méthodes
appliquées
à taïwan où vous vivez elle pourrait
l'être en europe plus précisément en
france mais en fait pour être très
honnête c'est un peu tard en fait c'est
c'est un peu tard il fallait agir a
assez assez vite au niveau de ces
contrôles aux frontières est ce qu il
faut savoir aussi c'est que là en effet
la généralisation du port du masque
alors qu'il n'y a pas de cas un
véritablement domestique enfin il ya eu
une sortie nombre de cas récemment mais
donc il ya une forme spontanément en
fait de mettre un masque il est au fait
que les taiwanais même quand ils ont
simplement la grille pour un rhume être
déjà le masque donc le masque est pas
considérée comme forcément invasif et
c'est une pratique courante et donc qui
en est fait sans la seule manière de
gérer deux cas très tôt je suis
difficile maintenant de suivre un
exemple si ce n'est évidemment
aujourd'hui le le vaccin pour l'europe
le vaccin qui n'est pas encore arrivée
qui commence petit à petit à être être
prévu pour arriver à taïwan merci
beaucoup jean resort stabilise d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl je le rappelle vous êtes
maître de conférences à l'université
catholique fuzhen à taipei mais
également chercheur associé au centre
d'études français sur la chine
contemporaine